[موسيقى]
من منكم استخدم تشات جي بي تي حتى يحل
واجب او يكتب تقرير يرفع ايده خليكم
صريحين استخدامه سهل وتحس انه يفهم عليك
ويقدر يساعدك في اغلب الاحيان تشات جي بي
تي هو صوره على تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي
حاليا واكيد كلنا شفنا اخبار وسمعنا خبراء
وشو قرينا تقارير تتكلم على سرعه تطور
الذكاء الاصطناعي وقدرته في تغيير
مستقبلنا
وحياتنا شفنا رايه تكلم على مخاوف ومخاطر
توصل انه ممكن يسيطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
علينا يا اخ مكاننا ويتحكم
بمصيرنا شفنا راي ثاني بالعكس متفائل
وشايف ان ذكاء الاصطناعي ح يستخدم صح
وحيكون احسن اداه قادره انها تحسن حياتنا
في كل
المجالات غالبا لو ما كانت عندك خلفيه
علميه تقنيه صعب تفهم بالضبط شنو الذكاء
الاصطناعي او كيف حياثر
عليك هل هو نفس مستوى ذكائك هل ممكن ياخذ
مكانك وكيف شنو في ايدك
تدير بس قبل الذكاء الاصطناعي العالم مر
بتطورات مختلفه وتطورات الصناعيه
مختلفه قبل اكثر من 250 سنه الانتاج
اليدوي بدا يتحول لاستخدام الات
الميكانيكيه والطاقه
البخاريه بعدها اكتشاف الكهرباء النفط
تطوره الصناعه وتسهلت وتسرع وتسهل وتسرع
الانتاج وبدا استخدام خطوط الانتاج
اللي فيها اشخاص بتقوم بشغل معين بطريقه
تكراريه واغلبنا اكيد عاش الثوره الصناعيه
الثالثه الكمبيوتر والانترنت ثوره تقنيه
بضغطه زر تقدر توصل وتعرف اي معلومه في اي
مكان وفي اي
وقت فرص جديده ومجالات جديده وبدت اثمت
الانتاج نتذكر لما كنت صغيره تفرجت على
فيلم تشارلي ومصنع ش
ف هالفيلم والد تشارلي يشتغل في مصنع في
خط انتاج وظيفته انه يسكر غطاء معجون
اسنان في يوم من الايام راح والد تشارلي
للشغل واكتشف انه تم تبديله بروبوت ذراع
اليه تقدر تقوم بشغله تسكر غطاء معجون
الاسنان الاف المرات من غير ما تتعبر
وتطلب اكل ولا استراحات فالعمر الصغير
المشهد هذا خل نستوعب ان الشخص لو ما وقب
التطوير وحسه من نفسه حيتم
تبديله اليوم عايشين الوره الصناعيه
الرابعه دكا اصطناعي تطور تكنولوجي سريع
اجهزه ذكيه روبوتات والات قادره انها تدير
انتاج مصانع بالكامل من غير اي تدخل
بشري تغيرت نمط تغيرت نمط حياتنا تغير
تفكيرنا وحتى طريقه تواصلنا مع بعض واكثر
يميز وقتنا هذا هو الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتطوره قبل اكثر من قرن ذكاء الاصطناعي
كان حلم وان الاله ممكن تتعلم وتفكر نفسنا
نفس الانسان كان خيال
علمي اليوم مع التطور صار واقع ف خلونا
نفهمه او نعرفه ببساطه شنو هو الذكاء
الاصطناعي هو نفس ما قلنا ان الكمبيوتر
يتعلم ويفكر وياخذ قرارات بطريقه شبهنا
حاليا اكثر نماذج ذك الاصطناعي المتطوره
معتمده عليه
خوارزميات مستوحاه تشتغل بطريقه مستوحاه
من طريقه عمل العقد البشري والخلايا
العصبيه وطريقه نقل المعلومات والتعلم
منها يتم تعليم ه النماذج على بيانات
مجموعه بيانات يحللها يتعلم الروابط بينها
ويستخدمها في حل مشكلات معينه للذكاء
الاصطناعي ثلاث مستويات
رئيسيه المستوى الاول الصناعي الضيق
هالمستوى اقل من مستوى ذكاء الانسان مهمه
محدده في مجال
محدد مستوى الاصطناعي مستوى الذكاء
الاصطناعي الثاني يع الذكاء الاصطناعي
العام نفس مستوى ذكاء الانسان مهام مختلفه
مجالات مختلفه يفهم مفاهيم جديده ويستوعب
السياق العام
والمنطق مستوى الثالث ذكاء الاصطناعي
الفائق يفوق ذكاء الانسان بمراحل كبيره
نفس الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي بنشوفها في
العاده في افلام الخيال العلمي وفي منشبه
الفرق بين الذكاء الاصطناع الفائق وذكاء
الانسان بنفس الفرق بين ذكاء الانسان
وذكاء
النمله نرجع تشات جي بي تي اكيد كلنا
جربناه وتفاعلنا معاه وانبهر بقدرته كيف
يقدر يتفاعل معنا ويجاوب مهما كانت اللغه
او
اللهجه مثلا سالت تشات جيبيت تي كيف حاله
باللهجه الليبيه وجاوبني شنو الجو باهي
ورد علي واسالني كيف حالي فبراي تشات جي
بي تي بكل امكانياتها هذه يعتبر ضمن اي
مستوى من مستويات الذكاء الاصطناعي
الضيق العام او
الفائق صح اغلبكم فكر انه ممكن يكون ضمن
مستوى ذكاء الصناعي العام لانه قادر
يتفاعل معنا بطريقه طبيعيه جدا ويفهم
يفهمنا ويجاوب لكن هو ضمن مستوى الذكاء
الاصطناعي الضيق لان قدرته محدوده وظيفته
محدده هي معالجه اللغه يعني يستقبل منك
الكلام النص يحلله ويرد
عليك طريقه عمله ولما يجاوبك حي جاوبك حسب
البيانات اللي متدرب عليها وحيح سب
احتماليه شن الكلمه او الجمله الاصح
بالنسبه لسؤالك واللي تدربب عليه ويجاوبك
هالنوع من الذكاء الاصطناعي هي نماذج ضخمه
نماذج لغه ضخمه احتاج السوبر كمبيوتر ودم
تم تدريبها تقريبا على كل
الانترنت يعني معلومات كبيره من كل
المصادر تخيل طالب عنده ذاكره فوتوغرافيه
جر مجموعه من الكتب واحفظها فلما تسل ح
يجاوبك حسب المعلومات اللي قراها في هذه
الكتب مثلا تسل كيف تصنع كرسي حي جاوبك
بخطوات الموجوده في كتب التصاميم اللي
قراها
سالت تشات جي بي تي كيف تصنع كرسي جاوبني
بخطوات على كيفيه صناعه كرسي
خشبي من غير ادراك انواع مختلفه من من
الكراسي من شنو مصنوع او كيفيه صنعه من
بلاستيك معدن ممكن ينطبع طباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد اجابته كانت محدده جدا يمكن لان
اغلب البيانات حسب البيانات اللي متدرب
عليها
اغلب المعلومات اللي لها علاقه بصناعه
كرسي هي على كرسي خشبي فهذه كانت اجابته
هنوع من ذكاء الاصطناعي يقدر يجتاز
امتحانات بسهوله يلخص لك كتب او يكتشف لك
اخطاء في
البرمجه اكيد استخدمه لكن كون واعي كيف
تستفيد منه وتتجنب الاخطاء انه ممكن
يجاوبك خطا او ممكن يعطيك اجابه
محدوده محيده ومتحيز نفس مصار مع مثال
الكرسي والكرسي المثال هذا جدا بسيط يعني
كل ما زاد تعقيد سؤالك كل ما زادت الحاجه
انك تتاكد من صحه المعلومات اللي تاخذها
مننا وما تعتمدش عليه اعتماد كلي لانه
ممكن يحد تفكيرك مستوى ابداعك لانه هو
ببساطه زي ما
نقولوا حافظ مش فاهم ولو تبي تتاكد تقدر
تساله هل انت حافظ مش فاهم حجاوب
عليك واكيد غير نماذج اللغه في نماذج اخرى
للذكاء الاصطناعي دقيقه جدا وفعاله في
مجالها نفس الذكاء الاصطناعي في تشخيص
الصور تشخيص الامراض من تحليل الصور
الطبيه او المستخدم في نظم التوصيه في
المتاجر الالكترونيه ووسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي حاليا 77% من الاجهزه حوالينا
تستخدم دكا اصناعي بشكل او اخر سيارات
اجهزه منزليه هواتف ذكيه
وغيره والاستخدام اكيد حيزيد مع
الوقت على شنو يعتمد تطور نماذج الذكاء
الاصطناعي
حاليا يعتمد على قوه
الكمبيوتر والبيانات المستخدمه للتدريب
وطريقه
التدريب قبل بس سنه علماء الذكاء
الاجتماعي علماء الذكاء الاصطناعي توقعوا
انه ممكن نوصل للذكاء الاصطناعي العام
اللي هو مستوه نس مستوى ذكاء الانسان سنه
245 لكن مع التطورات الاخيره هتوقع نزل
وصل لي سنه
227 يعني بس بعد اربع سنين يعني لو اللي
طالب جامعه سنه اولى احتمال يتخرج ويلقى
العالم والدنيا تغيرت دراسته وال الاشياء
اللي تعب عليها سنين حيطلع يلقى الذكاء
الاجتماعي اوردي قاعد يقوم بشغله ما فيش
حاجه لطريقه تقليديه
فتطور الذكاء الاصطناعي هو زي اي
تطور في ايجابيات
وسلبيات في مستفيدين و
متضررين فرص
وتحديات فكيف نقدر نضمن ان نكون في الجهه
المستفيده او هل هالشيء ممكن
اساسا هل في مهارات خطوات معينه لازم
نتبعها فدورت على الشيء هذا وبحثت وسالت
ولقيت ان في ثلاث خطوات اساسيه بسيطه ل
فعاله جدا واكتشفت ان الخطوات هذه ساعدتني
من قبل وحقول لكم بعدين
كيف الخطوات هذه هي
تعلم ابتكر
وبادر تعلم باستمرار تعمق في مجالك اكيد
لكن تعلم على الذكاء الاصطناعي وشوف كيف
تقدر انت تستفيد منه خلي يكون عندك اطلاع
على المجالات المختلفه ويكون عندك مهارات
تقنيه قويه هالشيء هذا يساعدك تتاقلم اسرع
مع التغيير
ويرفع فرصك
تنافسيه
ابتكر ما تكتفي انك تادي شغلك طريقه عاديه
وتقليديه وتكون مجرد مستهلك للتكنولوجيا
خلي تكون عندك افكار جديده حلول مبتكره
تفيدك وتفيد بها الناس ترفع من مستواك
وتحسن منك ممكن تفتح لك فرص
جديده ثلاثه بادر خليك الشخص اللي ياخذ
الخطوه للتغيير
الاحسن عندك حلول وافكار
مبتكره شوف كيف تقدر تبادر وتطبق الحلول
هذه بحث وتطوير رياده اعمال اسس مشروعك
طبق حلك وكون انت جزء اساسي من هالتغيير
والتطوير قلت لكم شخصيا هالنقاط هذه
الثلاثه ساعدتني المارات المختلفه
الاطلاع افكار مبتكره مبادره لكيفيه تطبيق
هذه الافكار واستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي مكني اني نقدر نبتكر طريقه
جديده جهاز يساعد في حل مشكله صحيه ويسهل
حياه
الناس اسواره ذكيه تقدر تراقب ضغط الدم
بطريقه ذكيه مستمره
ومريحه وزي ما هالثلاث خطوات هذه ساعدتني
ومتاكده انها حتقدر تساعدني اكثر في
المستقبل اكيد
حتساعدك في النهايه ما ننسو اكيد الجوانب
الانسانيه فالقرارات مش بس معتمده على
تحليل بيانات
مجرده لكن تعتمد ايض على عوامل اخرى نفس
الحكمه الخبره والقيم الاخلاقيه
والشخصيه حاجتنا للتواصل الفعال والتعاطف
بيننا وبناء العلاقات الانسانيه الجيده
مهما تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجيا
مستحيل حيلي حاجتنا للجوانب الانسانيه
كيف حيكون المستقبل بعد سنه خمس سنين ع
سنين او 50 سنه صعب نتوقع بالضبط لكن اللي
في ايدنا انه نكونوا مستعدين
وواعين بمخاطر وفوائد هذا التطور
شكرا